[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à lieutenant-colonel David un
hôtel représentant de la Fédération
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers de France
merci d'être là et merci à Karine un
témoin de l'explosion merci à vous deux
Karine je vous sens
pas bien
c'est normal vous allez voir l'explosion
a eu lieu au 277 rue Saint-Jacques à
Paris à l'Américan Paris Academy Nicolas
américaine et regarder la façade de
l'établissement c'est totalement
effondré donc on comprend que vous soyez
choqué regardez
qu'est-ce qui peut déclencher ce type
d'explosion colonel maintenant colonel
alors les hypothèses restent pour
l'instant soumis à interrogation on est
plutôt sur une hypothèse d'événements et
de d'explosion liés au gaz il y a
plusieurs témoignages qui font état
d'une odeur persistante de gaz dans le
quartier c'est a priori ce qui est mis
avant tout en avant maintenant le
parquet la procure de la République
reste prudente sur le sujet mais on est
a priori sur une 7 pistolet avant tout
les habitants ont indiqué sentir une
forte odeur de gaz avant l'explosion
c'est ça tout à fait sur quelques
minutes et une violente explosion qui
qui en plus a été combinée à un incendie
ce qui a rendu encore plus compliqué
l'action des collègues la brigade des
sampiers de Paris dans les premières
minutes fort heureusement l'incendie a
rapidement été circonscrit à diminuer
l'intensité qui n'avait pas été le cas à
Marseille on le sait sur au mois d'avril
sur l'explosion rue de Tivoli qui avait
duré plus longtemps alors les pompiers
ont fait de leur mieux ils ont été très
rapide bravo à vous encore vous étiez
plus de 270 sur les lieux regardez
il y a même l'armée qui a été déployée
regardez
[Musique]
alors apparemment le feu sera
actuellement circonscrit qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire en fait ça veut dire que le
feu a été contenu un volume défini il
est il est maintenu dans le périmètre
actuel et on n'a pas de crainte
particulière sur son expansion
effectivement a priori le sinistre est
désormais
circonscrit et l'action des secours à
pouvoir se concentrer sur les recherches
des potentiels victimes supplémentaires
puisque il est également donc on est sur
un bilan qui reste limité
malheureusement quand on voit l'état du
bâtiment donc on parle de quatre
personnes en urgence absolue et d'une
vingtaine de blessés plus légers mais
une hypothèse de deux personnes à minima
qui serait porté disparu dont on
n'aurait pas de nouvelles c'est un bilan
qu'il faudra Bénévent consolider tout au
long de la soirée peut-être encore plus
tard alors pourquoi on a évacué tous les
habitants des immeubles voisins en fait
alors on les a évacués pour deux raisons
parce que suite à une potentielle
explosion du haut gaz il peut y avoir le
gaz va s'échapper alors des poches de
gaz qui vont se former dans les
bâtiments le bâtiment en question et les
bâtiments adjacents et puis on a
également bien évidemment suite à la
violence de l'exodon vous voyez l'état
du bâtiment vous voyez on avait des
images également qui circulaient sur le
bâtiment d'en face ou le feu s'est
propagé de par la violence de
l'explosion on a des fragilités qui se
mettent en place donc on a on l'avait vu
une fois de plus à Marseille où les
bâtiments environnants avaient été
évacués sont encore pour certains
inhabités donc on est par mesure de
précaution obligé d'évacuer les les
bâtiments adjacents et puis pour
faciliter également l'action des secours
on a malheureusement une partie des
personnes qui ont tendance à vouloir
s'avancer vers les lieux de
l'intervention on ne peut que leur
rappeler que c'est pas la chose à faire
mais que forcément le périmètre de
sécurité va être plus large pour
faciliter l'action des secours et
l'évacuation ensuite des blessés qui
seront assumés vers les différents
hôpitaux de du secteur l'incendie peut
reprendre il est peu probable après on
peut on ne peut jamais totalement
s'avancer mais au vu du dispositif en
place ça reste probable ce qu'il est à
l'heure actuelle plus important de
contrôler de dimensionner c'est de
pouvoir identifier l'origine si fuite de
gaz il y a eu l'origine de cette fuite
et de et de pouvoir
identifier les les éléments en cause bon
les services dans ces cas-là
les services de gazier sont présents et
font la font les coupures nécessaires
pour voir intervenir en toute sécurité
juste pour savoir il y a des bons
habitants qui donc qui ont été évacués
quand est-ce qu'ils vont pouvoir rentrer
chez eux c'est quoi la la procédure en
fait alors là la temporalité va être
très différente selon la proximité ceux
qui sont à vraiment contiguës au
bâtiments ça va être plusieurs heures
voire peut-être plusieurs jours ça se
passe là ils vont être logés ils vont
être logés par les services de la mairie
tout à fait alors dans un premier temps
dans leur famille des voisins on leur
pose la question un très concrètement
dans ces cas-là si c'est pas possible
son voisin ce que vous pouvez prendre
des gens à eux est-ce que vous avez de
la famille dans le coin si c'est
possible c'est toujours plus agréable
d'aller suite à une catastrophe de ce
type d'être entouré de gens qu'on
connaît et puis c'est que lorsqu'il est
lorsque c'est impossible les services de
la mairie mettent à disposition des
hébergements provisoires d'accord Karine
merci d'être avec nous
vous avez entendu un gros bruit vous
étiez où moi j'habite au milieu de la
rue Henri Barbusse
c'est juste derrière le Val de Grâce
c'est pas un gros bruit c'était une
explosion mais une déflagration j'étais
en télétravail là vous entendez une
déflagration
d'une violence inouïe j'avais jamais
entendu ça ma vie mon fils était dans sa
chambre il est accouru on savait pas ce
qui se passait comme il y a une il y a
des le CROUS qui est en construction en
face on a cru que c'était un énorme grue
qui était tombée et puis très vite ou
pas en fait pas devant mais mon fils ça
donne derrière côté Val de Grâce et on a
vu un nuage de fumée monté à une vitesse
démesurée on a eu très très peur parce
que les murs en trembler avec une
violence et le canapé a bougé et du coup
comme on a vu l'avion on savait pas ce
que c'était on s'est précipité dans
l'ascenseur pour descendre et quand on
est arrivé en bas de la rue on a vu des
gens qui couraient dans tous les sens on
va au croisement de la rue Henri
Barbusse et Val de Grâce et là on
comprenait pas ce qui se passe c'est les
gens nous disent mais courez courez il y
a le gaz le gaz et tout le monde est en
panique ça courait dans tous les sens et
en fait on le en même pas 10 minutes il
y a un périmètre de sécurité qui s'est
déployée l'armée les pompiers les
policiers des infirmiers enfin comment
on est à la proximité de Cochin de
maternité de Port-Royal tout en
périmètre ils ont bouclé absolument tout
le quartier et moi je suis pas rentré
chez moi depuis parce qu'on pouvait pas
jusqu'à maintenant enfin jusqu'à mon
départ vous êtes vous êtes descendu
quand même pour parce qu'on a eu peur on
savait pas ce que c'était tout de suite
vous avez
pas si on était en sécurité vu que il y
avait c'est une énorme c'est une grosse
explosion on savait pas ce qui se
passait ou pas
vu la violence de l'explosion sur le
coup oui
sincèrement j'ai jamais mon a vécu j'ai
vécu adolescente les attentats à
Saint-Michel et les sentiments de
revivre ça sur le coup mais bon ça avait
pas on voulait pas de
tirer de conclusion alors est-ce que
d'autres immeuves peuvent s'effondrer ou
pas du tout alors il y a toujours un
risque de cette explosion on est sur des
bâtiments qu'on a un certain âge aura un
âge certain donc il y aura dans un
premier temps là les actions des secours
avant pied vont être de localisés
d'éventuelles victimes mais également de
pouvoir commencer à étudier d'un peu
plus près la structure parce que les
sauveteurs font également qu'ils
travaillent en sécurité et puis il y a
tout un dispositif et tout un
processus qui va se mettre en place avec
la visite de d'architecte et les
vérifications nécessaires pour bien
évidemment réintégrer les habitants
uniquement dans les bâtiments qui ne
présenteront pas de danger car ils vont
vraiment vous êtes
je suis choquée pour les pour les gens
surtout qui sont là vous avez vu des
gens sous les sous les décomptes et non
j'ai pas vu on a pas vu on a vu juste un
nuage de feu et de fumée on ne pouvait
pas accéder mais bon c'est un quartier
le cinquième et un quartier très très
familial très village donc on connaît
tout le monde et voilà vous êtes
inquiète pour peut-être des gens que
vous connaissez
qui je devais aller mon rendez-vous
aujourd'hui je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
enfin voilà j'avais peur
et qui était dans le dans l'immeuble au
niveau du 300 pas très loin de ah ouais
d'accord et donc vous avez pas réussi à
le joindre aujourd'hui vous êtes
inquiète pour lui donc un peu
ce qui est terrifiant avec ses
explosions un gaz notamment en milieu
urbain c'est que c'est soudain c'est
d'une ampleur incroyable et on a tous
peur au-delà du drame de la propagation
c'est ça
comment ça se passe pour éviter que ça
se propage alors il y a effectivement
l'effet de l'explosion il y a l'effet de
la sidération madame en est le parfait
témoin on est effectivement de part
cette agitation qui se crée vraiment des
conséquences qui sont importantes après
malheureusement j'aurais tendance à dire
que lorsque l'explosion s'est passée on
peut estimer que le gaz qui était en
train de s'échapper en raison d'une
fuite mais ce sera aura disparu mais la
meilleure des solutions c'est quelque
part ce qu'a fait madame c'est d'évacuer
le secteur nous on va pouvoir arriver
sur les lieux on a des appareils de
mesure en complément des services de Gaz
de France ou de GrDF qui vont également
compléter mais ça va être ça va passer
par des campagnes de mesure
effectivement pour identifier
d'éventuelles autres poches de gaz mais
il y a cette gestion des premières
victimes de l'incendie et également de
pouvoir intervenir en sécurité même si
c'est notre métier avant tout on est
aussi là pour prendre des risques de
temps mais surtout de d'éviter à la
population qui serait encore présente
dans le secteur de subir une deuxième
explosion alors la plupart des habitants
étaient bien sûr sous le choc de
nombreuses personnes âgées se trouvaient
proches du lieu de l'explosion cette
dame a reçu des débris chez elle
regardait son état même obligé BFM TV à
rendre l'antenne regardez
il y avait des gens j'ai entendu aux
nouvelles qui avaient
[Musique]
on va peut-être vous laisser qu'ils
avaient emmené à minima 4 blessés graves
et alors pour vous dites-nous qu'est-ce
qui va se passer vous pouvez peut-être
pas rentrer chez vous tout de suite pour
dormir vous allez chez votre sœur
ok on va vous laisser on va laisser la
dame se reposer parce que elle est assez
choquée donc voyez c'est ce que je vous
disais les gens qui ont vécu ça sont
assez choqués on va appeler les secours
donc on va vous rendre l'antenne
Karine c'est vrai que quand vous voyez
ça vous je comprends c'est on est à base
sur Lyon
mais je voulais saluer en tout cas le
travail des des ils ont été incroyables
en 10 minutes ils ont pris mais tout de
suite même pas 10 minutes il y avait
toute le cordon de sécurité ils nous ont
demandé d'évacuer ils ont ils ont
contrôlé toute la population parce que
toujours des voyeurs qui veulent filmer
des choses comme ça et ils ont ils ont
fait vraiment un travail incroyable que
ça soit les pompiers les mains les
militaires les policiers
de toutes vous en avez aussi les
médecins je pense que on va pouvoir être
autorisé bientôt à rentrer normalement
oui
je sais pas c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué c'est important c'est que on
l'a vu là avec la personne c'est
qu'au-delà des blessures physiques dans
ce cas de figure là c'est ça sur des
événements aussi brutaux qui touchent au
lieu d'habitation également c'est pas
anodin il y a les blessures
psychologiques et il y a beaucoup de
gens certainement effectivement on avait
parlé une fois de plus je me répète sur
l'explosion de Marseille mais il y a
énormément de gens qui seront
certainement qui ont un besoin
d'accompagnement dans les prochains
jours les prochaines semaines il faut
surtout pas hésiter à en bénéficier
c'est tout à fait compréhensible